hello everyone this is during work with
a little Sinclair so in the random cross
em oh well there are no customers
establishes probability distribution for
the sub graph of a graph G and two
parameters of NH probably DB and a
closer wake you an issue graph of the
form be a where a is a set of the edges
of the wrap please if your weight and
the weight is given by this expression
here where you have a pre factor for
each edge in the configuration a 1 minus
P factor for each edge that is not in
the configuration and then a Q factor
for each connected component so here Co
face a number of kinetic component of
the new suit grad P a so here's an
example the graph here is c4 and the way
did receive is given by this term here
where for example you have one edge so
you have one factor of P that trick on
at the component so you have Q 2 3 and
so on so this is an important model
because essentially unifies the story of
Sarah or moles that are important that
that we get a lot so for example if you
see here if you take Q equals 1 the mall
reduces to a standard bond percolation
mall where every edge is sample
independently with probably DP to divert
subgraph of g in particular if the graph
G is a complete graph then this is the
address range a random graph ah Jim p.m.
oh ok Moroi when when q is an interior
this model is dual in a precise sense to
a ferromagnetic ec none unbowed small
and it just to be slightly more precise
what i mean by dual is that there is a
prolific coupling of the random cross a
measure and the ferromagnetic is
important measure such that we can map
correlations in the Spinward two paths
in the end edge in the Asheville and we
can use this connection to prove
interesting stuff or the ECM other
species spin systems
in addition you can see that if we take
for example q smaller than 1 then we
favor configurations that do not have
many components so in particular if Q
goes to 0 the set of limits arise for
body choices of P include our
interesting distribution or the Sioux
graph of G for example we can choose P
such that the run across American values
to the uniform measures or the spanning
trees or the spanning force or the or
over the connected subgraph of g again
in this small it makes sense to talk
about the measure in the inland pine a
graph and here is an alternative
definition although we can define it in
the same way as as what defining the
preview stock we can consider a sequence
of graph that converges to something
finer graph G and then the running costs
are mentioned in this in finite graph is
just the limiting measure of of the
sequence of measures an inch of this car
so here is an example suppose we
consider the run across a mall in a box
square box in the internal audit graph
then we take the if we do this the limit
and the on the side of the box as n goes
to infinity n is the size of it again to
go to infinity the limit in May the
limiting graph is going to be the in
final intel r this graph and this way we
this is the way we find the run across a
measure in the in finite large claw so
again here we have the question of when
this limit is unique but that will not
be a focus off of this tour so
important future of them all is that
there is the phase transition or it is
conjecture that there is this ray
sensation so we have a critical value of
the mall parameter P such that with high
probability pieces more than this
critical point all components are finite
and as soon as priests lighted on this
critical point then there is at least
one in final component for example if
you go back to see to this critical body
is none it was recently shown by before
and Dominic Cuban that it corresponds to
the surf do a point but in general we we
only partially understand the face
incision and we only listen in some
classes of graph in the finite setting
we can roughly think that this face
incision corresponds to the emergence of
the giant component just like in the EMP
case
so the focus off of this dog and the
focus off of my work is to understand
the behavior of micro chains on Brandon
closer configurations so these are micro
change that the state space are the hand
of all the running coffee configurations
of a given graph G and the stationary
distribution of this micro Shane is
going to be a random closer measure and
in particular I'm interested in we're
interested in understanding the mixing
time with micro shane since I'm one of
the first talks I'm going to just say
what it is is just a number of steps the
teaching has to take to take until is
close to the stationary measure assuming
edgy stuff from there was a possible
starting configuration so well by now we
know that there is a well-established
connection with in phase transition and
the behavior of micro chains for example
we know of many faiths incision that
changes the substantially the mixing
time of some micro chains but on the
other hand we in many other moles we
have been using for for many years now
we have been using mixing times of
bodies micro shame to understand the
face of structure of this mouse so there
is a two-way connection here in addition
well we know that fast fast mixing
machines provide are going for sampling
from the stationary measure and in
particular the run across the dynamics
is also interesting because it is very
is but it's close related to a spin
systems but the knicks from a spin
system seems to fail in the random
closest setting essentially because
these techniques are used the locality
of the screen world and the random cross
the mall is a highly non local mall
because connectivity is a global
property of the RAF so this is one of
the main questions that we were
interested in as the standard he bought
my crocheting which is a global dynamics
and the way it goes is as follows you
have some random cross sometime across a
configuration a and we began edge
uniformly at random from the graph and
the edge gets I with this probability
here and this probability is essentially
the probability that the edge is in the
configuration if we condition on a minus
E otherwise the HT remove it this is
a dynamics that is defining many moles
and have been studied many moles so this
expression in the case of the random
closet law has this now nice just this
nicest pressure here where we have it is
equal to P if is a correction and we say
that an edge is the cottage if it
doesn't change the number connected
component of the graph by are in or
remove the edge otherwise is given by
this expression so here is an example
here you have Sun run across a
configuration in the six-by-six agree
you big at random edge say that one that
one ISA bridge is the cottage because it
changes a number connected component
saying that so it gets I'll with this
probability so then we big this one this
one is in a cycle so it's not a good
edge so it gets removed with 480 1 minus
P so the other dynamics that I'm going
to be telling you allowed this talk is
the change master Marco shame and eagles
are follow we have a random closer
configuration a and in the first step we
were component by component and we
activate each connected component
independently with 21 our cue right then
we will add each active edge
independently with probability be our
wives we will remove it okay let me
before I I show you an example I just
want to say that it is straightforward
to check that this converges to the
random closer measure and that as you
can see from this step here it's only
well defined when q is greater than one
so I this probably says on one actually
hdhd the joints triggers is the second
version or to the HR to be present now
it's an active fascist an edge that the
both endpoints were active it doesn't
have to be the same component if you
listen in the same component it is
active but it can be from different
components so here is here is an example
again we have the 6 by sigrid the first
step every component gets activated
independent with probably 1 over Q so
here at the or the orange ones are the
ones that got activated we forget the
configuration in the in that region in
the active region and we're example
every edge with prolific so we had found
new configuration there
and then this is one one step of the
change master micro Shane this as well
now it's easy to see that this
substantially different the two dynamics
i just described the hip bath is a local
process that changes one at a time well
the CM dynamics is a global process that
change in many edges and in a spin
systems it is known that some of this
glow and micro chains are fasters that
faster than the local contact part in
fact substantially faster is on dreams
but our first theorem in here shows that
this is not the case in the random
closer more here we show that it's a
comparison inequality within the the
mixing time of the hip bath under shake
master and it shows that if we are sure
that the we can show you if we have
another bomb for the mixing time of the
global macro Shane then we get an upper
bound for the hip bath and the same for
the lower bound and we only pay
polynomial factors in this so we show
this by generalizing a technique of a
comparison technique of of Ulrich so I
won't tell you much about the proof of
this just I just ready for a play this
can be constant degree any graph yeah
this isn't for the comparing the in a
random closest ally in this if you go to
a spin systems and you have this
restriction with the degrees so it
expensive way then all which is wrong
you know if it is expensive one this
horse but if you want to compare the
swanson one with the heat back in the
spin systems then danger by the dubai
tell you ok so the talk is going to have
to part in there in the first part I'll
okay in the first part I will tell you
all the sump results on the shake master
mixing time in the mean field and in the
second part I will tell you about some
result on the mixing time for the hip
bath dynamics in in-situ just a quick
question does the comparison estimate
also revival is this generalization
chase mechta where instead of having
activating or not activating you give
each cluster the color between one and
an integer column between one and a flow
of Q and then you Wis ample within each
concept direction is the comparison
house in that case so the comparison was
actually proof for that case by ulrich
and what we did was just pulled it for
our K equals Q where Q is integer just
area for a ninja so he proved this okay
minus three no way and i'll choose a top
hours and choose two colors and each
cluster will get our with ability 1 over
Q to be read with probability 1 over Q
to be blue and otherwise it's inactive
and now you lis something inside the
blue and inside ah this in the paper
towards the end and they claim that it's
supposed to be fastest if you choose the
largest possible number of columns yes I
excellent work right yeah I'm not sure
if we were all there but the point is
that this the whole comparison in
equality holds in a more general setting
that what was proofing the Ulrick savvy
so what I put here is just a special
case of the generalization that were
able to prove so maybe horses and that's
arena haha touche ok so the in the first
spot as i say i'm going to talk about
the mean field and the mean field is the
case where g is a complete graph and
this is a useful non-trivial starting
point in most with a statistical physics
motivation we usually start here then we
go to random graph and ultimately we
want to understand what is going on in
high-dimensional a DS so the interface
incision here we have a bday
parameterize p / as lambda or n and
there is a clinical body of lambda that
is given by this expression here and we
know that if if lambda is more than and
acrylic at then all components the
largest components the large component
has size log N and as soon as landslide
another critical the largest component
is going to be a linear size and it's
going to be Sid RN and see the RS we
know what it is and it's a function of
landa and key so this is work by bulova
screaming johnson and lucia can do ship
for a few years back they have been some
some work on the mixing time of Markov
chains they mean field but most of this
previous work has been for this when
someone dynamics which is a similar
dynamic to see a 2-cm dynamics but it's
only a fine for into a queue for Q
equals for example for ki rasoi on we
fully understand the mixing time of the
expansion one dynamics and this is work
by Cooper edoran and long at all and
until recently we only had partial
results for the interior interior
curator or equal than three regime and
this was the work biker and German and
horror but in an independent work two
hours we now have the full picture of
the missing time for this 1714 interior
cube there you go down three and you
will hear more about this isn't to motor
but the point I want to make is that the
Swenson one is it's not a very natural
dynamics for the random cross em all
because it's only fine for interior q it
uses the connection with a spin system
while the run across them all is well it
makes sense for every real value of of Q
okay so this is our first resolver
concerned emission time and it's
essentially a complete analysis of the
mixing time so when when q is between
one and two we show that the mixing time
is of the same dynamics is see the log n
for all non-critical bodies of plunder
now when q is greater than to the here
is more interesting we show that there
is a regime around the critical point
where the dynamics is essentially
exponential is slow and as soon as
lambda is not in that window then the
mixing times we gone very fast it is
actually cedar log on and there is also
this interesting behavior in one of the
boundary points where we have a power
law for the mission time in the first
case
the routine should be n right good and
should be n yeah in fact this uh this is
a silly in my to-do list but should be
in here and i will tell you also the
Robin problems what is going on with
this critical point amazing thing up in
atlanta art as well is it not known Oh
landau r is also a special I mean the
sense of the analysis is different but
it has the same log and mixing time ok
so now I'll give you some interpretation
of the results why we have this big
changing behavior wearing cue goes from
from one to two and it goes down to the
continuity of the face transition so
when when q is between one and two we
know that there is this second order
phase transition with means that the
phase transition is continuous or very
smooth and if here the x axis is the
size of the largest component here we
are probably the we see that in the
subcritical we have only one motor and
settle again in the supercritical around
seed RN and even in the critical in the
critical regime we also have only one
mode so it is a very smooth face
transition but as soon as skew is
greater than to the face incision
becomes discontinuous so in the critical
point we'll have two modes for the size
of the largest closes the each one
roughly half accounts for roughly half
of the probability math right so this is
the phenomena of phase coexistence but
when in a short neighborhood around in
closer in clothes over around this
critical point we see that these two
modes are still present in a photo in a
form of a second log of maximum maximum
of the destroyed a mass and the states
that are here at the so called meta
stable states that are arrested that
trap demarco Shane so if you say that my
crocheting from there the micro Shane
cannot leave that states in polynomial
number of steps and this is where why we
can show that the machine time between
London and our is also equally
suspension
okay so just to give you a flavor of a
lot of proof did you attend to that
slide azizam what what is the picture on
the right this one so these this picture
is saying that the size of the largest
cluster is concentrated around a linear
has a linear size and it's were
concentrated around this around this
point so what is the difference between
those three it's just where the meeting
what were the main is yeah so yeah so
here what the mean is this this is
yes yes the behavior is much more
complicated salad at the Q equals 2 case
so we showed two bonded mixing time we
use the coupling technique we
essentially will study micro shine we
aside from two arbitrary we would
realize two copies and Mike Oceana
starting from arbitrary initial
configurations and we we would we know
that if at some time T the probability
that the Chinese norco ball is bounded
by some constant then this is bound for
the mixing time this time provides a
month around for the mixing time so the
our coupling we have two main phases in
the first phase will run the change
independently until the size of the
largest component initiate any chain has
roughly the right size and in the second
phase then we are going to gobble the
evolution but now I starting from two
configurations that have the right combo
that right largest component size so
here is the an overview of the first
face and hear the gear of salvation is
the draw a picture here so you have some
sometimes on closer configuration these
are the components and in the first step
I activate some chunk of I activate a
fraction of the components is that ITA
this one's here I'll forget so this is a
CMS step in the semester then I forget
our dash configuration and I resample
every age who is probably be here so
essentially what i'm doing is i'm
replacing a fraction of of the graph
with a year m.p random graph or EIT p
random graph in one step and now we can
use these two to analyze the evolution
of the micro shame for example in the
face 1a we can show that after lo n
steps that is going to be our most one
large component and this is because we
know that a GM Piron ography even if it
is too critical supercritical we have at
most one this is easy to see how if you
have many they would counsel in a few
steps of the dynamics
yay the meaning the most interesting
phases phase 1b where now we have this
large cluster and we want to analyze how
the change of the closest changes as we
are dynamic progresses and if we use a
here using a low of XT for the largest
cluster is easy to show that when l FX
is inactive this speculation step is
going to be a su critical step so all
the new components are a creator of
sites log n with very high probability
so the size the largest component will
not change but II fell off axis is
active then the number of active
components were is given by this where
you have sit at the end with which is
the size of a largest component and then
you have a cube fraction of the
remaining vertices and the new largest
component is going to be largest
component of a GMP random graph so this
will give us a drift function for the
size of the righteous component that I
wrote here so it's for this oppression
and now we look at how this function
looks and we see that between one and
two the function looks like this where
if lambda is in the su critical am the
reef is always negative and this makes
sense because if you're the security
gate regime the regime and you have a
large component you want to destroy the
large component but if lambda is the
supercritical team it has 10 and the
silicon respond to expect a body of the
other ideas component if it is a smaller
than the expected value we see that it
is positive and this again this is what
we want and if it is larger that least
is negative so it's always up converging
to this expected body okay so everything
is nice here so the critical point
corresponds to this core fear the first
time it has a zero okay but when we go
to Q rather than 2 k's the drift
function looks quite differently when
lambda is a smaller than lambda L well
again this is always negative and this
in the superior so this is good when
land is slightly the lambda are we again
have the same behavior have the cedar
here corresponding to expected value but
this behavior does not go all the way to
the critical point this curve here
correspond to a land I'll and land are
our treat and if lambda is actually for
some for the values of lambda where
lambda l and r the curve we
two zeroes instead of non or one what
this means is that for ISA in the SU
critical case this portion of the curve
here is positive so this means that
you're in the soup critical case you do
in the stationary solution you are not
likely to have a large component but
here on expectation you're going to
increase the size of the component so
this we essentially this is that what we
are able to use to show that the mission
time is too slow within lambda L on and
are so here are the two special point
the participate the curve corresponded
to reduce three points lambda l and r
and we see that the main issue here is
that there are these two zeroes here and
the drift essentially becomes zero in
these points so we have two something
different because we have negative or
treat and if i were able to use is the
that is actually enough buttons to push
you out of of this interval
okay so now that was about face one in
phase two is when we actually do the
coupling of the micro Shane but now we
can assume that the two largest
component have roughly the same size
here the key the key step is going to be
to couple the activation of the
components in a way that softly the sign
up for exactly one is that they cyclist
the same number of vertices are active
are active in each copy because once we
if we are able to activate the same
number of bodies in both copies then we
can put an arbitrary variation within
the edges are you and use this variation
to the sample all the edges and get the
same component structure in the active
sub graph so you can invite now that if
you have the same component of structure
structure in the active graph all you
need to do is to go the whole
configuration and then you will achieve
two sub graph with the same component
structure after you achieved to sue
graph with the same component structure
that is a no coupling argument but this
is a simple argument that takes you from
two configurations with the same
component instruction to do
configurations that are the same but the
key in this phase two is how to cover
the activation to ensure that with some
probability that the configuration have
exactly the number of active boluses the
same number of activities so this is how
it is done so suppose that this had two
copies of the micro Shane we will call
the activation of the two year and
components where and after that we will
create a machine within other components
with the restriction that we were first
we will denote in order isolated
vertices and the restriction that we put
is that we only match components of
equal size right now and then after we
put that maximum with the maximum
maximum machine here in a and we use the
maximum machine to activate to activate
the components so here after doing the
activation with a machine we don't
create any difference between the two
copies so we have the same number of
activities involved then we do the
activation in the end component but from
phase one we know that the difference
between the two is small so there is
some discrepancy that is created here
but it's not too large and indeed we put
the remaining components here we do it
independently and this again creates a
more discrepancy once the bodies had
since all these components are small the
discrepancy is also not too
so overall you can create a discrepancy
that is a folder children with constant
probability and then you observed that
the isolated by this is the number of
active isolated by this is a binomial
random barrio so you do a coupling of
the binomials here and try to use this
goblin to fix whatever this click
currency was created from WS activation
so you can you know I've healed some
some details here but this is
essentially what is going on okay and
that was that's it for the face well the
two sides of the dog so in the this and
the last part now if you choose somalia
gong you can come back now because this
is a fairly different argument where we
analyze the the heat bath the logan
marco shane in situ so remember that the
heat bath is this micro Shane what we're
looking at the finite boxes of the
Interior lattice graph and we began
under match and the HGC guess I with
this priority so there is some there is
some previous work and this was done by
this result of Ulrich I mean this is a
more general result but when applied to
to a hip bath in situ we get this
polynomial pawn of n to a cig log square
and this will hope for our entire bodies
of Q and all non-critical bodies of P so
the these this resort has some Sun
robots well first it only holds four
into a queue the bounce which produces
are not very strong so that we program
your bounds and also the proof call a
comparison argument which is indirect so
it fails to show any kind of connection
with the phase transition our resort for
the heat bath is a tight bond for the
mission time of n Square log n for all
curator eager than one unknown on
critical values of P
the sideline and is the silence so it's
a professional to number of edges over
Isis imbalances
so before giving you a flavor of the
proof I have to introduce the funerals
and one of them is this idea of boundary
conditions and the idea is that we want
to sometimes we want to understand the
random closer measure in the Box
conditional on some configuration in the
complement of the box so this
configuration in the compliment will
create some corner will induce some
connectivities in the boundaries and we
will use a partition of the vertices in
the boundary to encode this connectivity
so boundary condition is a partition of
the boundary where disease here is an
example the three vertices here I
connected through the exterior so they
are in the same element of the partition
and so on so here are a few more
examples that this at the two extreme
our case where all the veggies have wire
so this is called a wire boundary
conditioner this is the free boundary
conditions that know a boundary
conditions here and that is a special
class of boundary conditions that will
be important for us that we call the
size homogeneous boundary condition and
we find these boundary conditions as
follow we say essentially that there is
only one non-trivial element in the
partition so you only have one connected
component one non-sugar connected
component in the boundary and in
addition the boundary condition is
almost homogeneous across each side so
if it is if two bodies as a wire in one
side then the whole side has to be
worried so all of these here are sigh
homogeneous this tool as hyoma genius
this one is not because we have many
will have 3d non-trivial elements in the
partition and this one is not because it
is not homogeneous on this side or in
this side
so this the other notion that I have to
introduce is this idea of a special
mixing which is slightly different for
the London closer but listen for the
random closer more so here the idea is
that we look at an H E and we consider a
box of radius R around this edge and we
would like to measure the influence of
the configuration in the compliment of
this box on the state of the HD and for
that but we do what we do is we look at
this difference in the probability that
the edge is occupied condition on two
different configurations on the
compliment now if this difference decays
exponentially with the size of the box
and this holds for every edge then we
say that a special mixing holds for the
random closer more so special mixing is
closely related to the notion of
exponential decay of connectivity which
is this is a property for the infinite
measure and the felon dominic open
showed that in the infinite ladies we
have exponential decay of connectivity
at the priority that you and we are
connected decays exponentially with
distance in this rather subcritical
regime in previous work Alexander had
shown that if exponential account
connected really hold in the infinite in
the infinite laddies then we will would
also hold in the final boarding for
every 30 under conditions and then he
uses these exponential decay
connectivity to show that a special
mission hold for a restricted class of
boundary conditions and for interview
but we're able to do first is to use
them this machinery developed by
Alexander here to show that especially
missing holes for size homogeneous
boundary condition for also critical
bodies of P and 402 data record online
so here let me give you an idea of why
special mixing is susceptible to the
boundary conditions because this is
actually different to a speed system so
first of all that you have this edge
here and the box does not touch the
boundary of the outer box the influence
from from the compliment can only goes
to E in the form of path
and bias potentially greater
connectivity we know that this path dks
the priority of this path decays
exponentially with our and this can be
turned into a legal side women but when
the edge is close to the boundary
increased or not does not only gowns
from this from the boundary of the box
it doesn't come from the only come from
the conflation it also comes from the
boundary condition of the outer box so
if the boundary condition is until I
distancing arbitrary like this you can
take influence from very far regions
from me too close to it using the
boundary condition okay so it means that
if I modify one side then the margin
alone or nay on the side that's distance
our family is exponentially the
difference is exogenous morning the
distance so what what I'm what I meant
what oh just special mix yeah I so I
being careful not using strong or weak
because the notions are not map I all
see them up in the same way to the tulip
in systems so what I mean is that if
they bump the bunt depending on the kind
of boundary conditions that you have in
El in the bigger box then you you could
have for you you may or you may not have
a special mixing in the whole box and
this is this effect hear that because
boundary conditions can actually connect
these kind of barriers like this you can
take influence from fat regions to agent
regions clothes we just using the
boundary condition of the outer box
but the point is that cipher moreno
valley' conditions avoid this phenomenon
we did this property that there is only
one non-trivial connected component by
component in the other boundary avoid
these this issue
okay so now here is the proof I sketch
our proof x case for our mantra so for
the Heba we we show that a special
mixing implies a fast fast mixing we
actually show that a mixing time is at
most n Square log n log log n square and
then we show this boosting lemma that
says that if you show that the mixing
time is at most n 2 a 2 plus epsilon 4
so sufficiently small epsilon then this
can be boosted to the right and square
lo n bar since since we know that lemma
1 lemma 1 we have a special mixing for
unknown critical body also critical
values of P and Q other than one then we
have that the mixing time industry
emissions we're logging now then we use
the set of duality of the mall to show
that if you have some by own bone of em
in the sub critical region then this can
be turned into a bond of order M for the
super critical review and finally we use
we prove that the mission time is lower
bounded by these which shows us that our
upper bounds are are tight okay so
the llama do we show that the special
makes it implies First Nations and this
is a notion that has been both around
for a while and it's been systems the
this work where it is show that especial
some notion of the gear correlation in
place in place fast mixing and i only
put here the ones that where we were
some inspiration for our work but there
are many more and again we're going to
use a coupling but in this case we're
going to use a specific coupling we are
going to use the identity gobbling and
in the lady the Goblin we pick the
center under match in both copies and
then we use the center under number to
decide where to either remove the edge
the identity goblin is a monotone
coupling which means that is at time t
YT is a subset of X T then this property
is preserved by the steps of this
coupling and one consequence of this is
a it is sufficient to consider as the
studying states that do extrema
configurations the one that has no edges
or the one that has all the edges ok so
our goal is going to redo bound the
probability that X T is not equal to YT
and for that we can work by Union bond
it is we can try to get a very good
bound on the priority at xt and YT
disarray in each edge and 21 this
probability we will consider two
additional process CD with minus and CD
plus C D minus will start on the empty
configuration just like the white copy
and CD plus we start from the complete
configuration just like the X 0 copy and
the four copies are going to recover
with the identity cobley the only
differences that sit down see the d- and
see that plus are going to ignore their
updates are outside some box of rivals
are around the HD so after T steps we
see that see that he has not performed
any updates here so that the minus an
operation days here and the same for
seated applause in addition by monitor
initially we see that see that the minus
is a subset of Y txt n and so so by
monotonicity instead of bonding this
probability we can bound they're
probably at cd- and CD plus disagree in
the HD so here and here is the intuition
Hunter that we look at the stationary
measure of these two process and we see
that that is a random closer measure in
this smaller box with some boundary
condition this case the free and this
case the wire one so after sufficiently
large t we know that see that the minus
is going to be close to start to the see
that the miners and applause are going
to be close to the recessionary
distribution but in addition by a
special mixing we choose the size of the
Box sufficiently large we see that the
probability that these two stationary
measures this Heidi in the edge the case
is financially with the size of the box
so you can in mind that if the de- is is
close to to this one and see that the
applause is close to this one then the
broader they decided also decays
exponentially with the size of the box
this can be this sort of trauma
triangular inequality but the main
question is how how large should should
be big t such that CDs and CD CD my nose
and applause are close to the stationary
mention and here is where the second
property of sie Homer Jr wonder
condition becomes very relevant again so
the bond is that if we look this is at
the boundary condition in these smaller
boxes the boundary condition is this is
most boxes is always Saitama genius this
is clearly against the boss is the box
doesn't touch the boundary because it is
here the wire are the free but even if
the box touched the boundary since the
wires in the boundary condition in the
other box aside some a genius there
under the condition in the inner box is
like so McGinnis so this gives us some
kind of recurrence and in fact if we if
we are provided with some bounder on the
mixing time as a function of the of the
length of the of the side of side length
of the box we can get around on this T
by essentially nothing that after F
cedar log n steps the CD minus process
will have mixing this inner box we go a
little bit further to actually get very
close to a stationary machine and then
we have this a slowdown factor here
because this is essentially a lazy lower
global dynamics where only with quality
log square put volume over and n squared
the H is updated so we have this a lot a
slowdown factor so from a guarantee in
the mixing time we own we attain a new a
stronger guarantee so for example if we
start from a very three
double bond of e 2 n square after four
iterations of of this idea you get that
the mixing time is n square low and dog
level n square Inc minister so finally
in lemon lemon three I want tell you
much about this but it is a boosting
lemma where we if we start from from my
bound mixing turn up two blocks epsilon
which enter the recession which we
already have from from from the previous
result then we can boost it to try
answer and the idea is that instead of
establishing a recurrence for the
mission time we establish a recurrence
for this quantity here and the main new
ingredient to establish this recurrence
is the buckets to bound the speed at
which disagreements propelled this also
on a standard notion in a spin system
but hot that has to be modified to run
across a steady well we are able to show
okay let me tell you what I mean by the
speed of propagation of this agreement
so suppose that you have two
configurations that agree in some box
around the energy so they have the same
configuration inside this box but didn't
take this idea outside we want to
measure how many steps of the hiba
dynamic we need to actually propagate
those disagreements to the center of the
box and we are able to show is that we
are able to provide a bound on the speed
of this revelation essentially if the
probability that x and y a 10k and
square the feder e is bounded by this
expression here provided k is smaller
than our to a one-quarter r is the
radius of the boss
so this is how we adapt the notion of
privation of the sediments to a random
process setting so now this is so many
into this smaller box PDR what we do is
we consider this maximal region that
isolate the edge e from the boundary
from the boundary of the box so in this
case it looks something like this it
doesn't touch the boundary the point is
that the two configurations we know that
they are always going to add in this
kind of regions so we are going to
consider a sequence of these regions and
if we updates on edge is inside this
region the region is not modify if we
know if we change we update on edge that
is verified from this region that region
is also not modify but if we pick an
edge that is slightly in the boundary
then this can be problematic so what we
do is with something simple we just take
the whole component out of the region
again this XT and YT are always going to
are in this region there's we can the
key observation is that since we we
choose YT degree from the stationary
measure and we know we have this
exponential decay of connectivity
progresses so all the components are
small we actually need many updates to
reach the center of the works and if we
don't sing well and this is an unlikely
event if we don't take too many steps as
a of the micro Shane okay so for open
problems so for the Winfield we from the
comparison ago idea with your should
show we get some bounds on the mixing
time they are roughly into a 2 a 4 we
seen that the right answer is n to n
square but we don't have a good way of
analyzing this in situ the domain of a
problem is the analysis of this click on
point and here is a no soul ball
conjecture that the mixing time should
be polynomial for Q's more equal than
for an exponential for period and
foreign began this is based on a
conjecture about the continuity of of
the face incision that is widely
believed under Q equals 2 is no
at Q equals 2 is known for four days emo
but yeah yeah but that's just the he
busts for speed for the ECMO it it's not
known for the Q equals two for the
random closet but some sunshine is known
for the the listening of the keyboard
suitcase is much better and then there
has been this recent development
regarding the the continuity of the face
incision so there is some hope on least
getting some partial results for the
mixing time at a critical point and
beyond this we would like to understand
random process hammocks in general graph
and 01 Reggie questions
they don t speak needs 40 somehow extend
to so-called none available graphs like
Gosnell go to pop you mean the number
amenable yes well in yes we know that
spin system these techniques holds in
more general settings the but we all
have a special mention for the random
closer in more general settings so that
would be what i will be doing us at a
point but we also see that these
specimens in public halls in more
generality but we have to start there
the other question
okay let's take this figure again